You're saying different for our third
show,
we're going to get away from atheism and
religion today,
believe it or not,
and we're going to focus on another
passion of mine politics.
Real quick though.
I should thank all of you that listened
to last week's direct message and
actually took it into action.
You guys are calling out the bullshit
artists on every social media platform
like I've never seen before.
As I said last week,
when you guys are engaged,
we can focus on other things and not
just have the same conversation over and
over.
Uh,
I've really only been intimately
involved in this conversation for a
couple of weeks fighting the lies.
It's not only exhausting,
but it has also affected a couple of my
friendships.
Uh,
I really do think that part of the plan
by these people is to tire out the good
guys and to giving up your part in this
debate is beyond crucial.
But enough of that.
Let's talk politics.
I was at the gop debate at the Reagan
Library last week.
I've never been to one of these things
before and I really had no idea what to
expect behind the scenes.
We had a booth in the spin room right
alongside CNN,
MSNBC,
and Fox News.
The fact that they call it the spin room
really tells you all you need to know
about this thing.
This is where campaign people and
candidates go to spin their message.
I went to the truth room next door,
but nobody was there.
Weird,
Huh?
We were able to snag surrogates from
pretty much every candidate except for
Carly Fiorina and Donald trump because
neither of them sent any reps to the
floor.
I even got to ask John a question about
gay marriage and Scott Walker,
a question about money in politics.
Come to think of it.
Maybe that's what caused him to drop out
of the race earlier this week.
What I realized by being on the inside
of all this is that there are some
unspoken rules to how the game is
played.
I talked to Mike Huckabee's,
campaign manager about gay marriage,
and she basically just danced around it.
Had I pushed her to the breaking point,
I probably would have never gotten
access to her again and then word would
have traveled fast that I'm someone that
they shouldn't talk to.
So with that in mind,
I tried my best to navigate all the
interviews with some basic questions and
then some deeper probing.
I asked pretty much everyone about
campaign finance and I really pushed on
social issues.
It was a big learning experience and
we'll figure out how to engage with the
candidates and the representatives in an
even more incisive way beyond the spin
and the sound soundbites.
Hopefully as the show gets bigger,
we'll get to more of the debates.
Candidates will eventually realize that
I'm going to be tough but honest,
uh,
whether we agree or not,
we're planning out our plan to go to the
first democratic debate and October
right now.
So stay tuned for that.
So for today's show,
we're going to jump back into the
political waters.
I've got two comics I like and respect
Jimmy,
Darren,
Felicia Michael's.
I agree with them on some issues and,
and,
uh,
disagree with them on some others.
What I know more than anything else
though is that comedians have a way of
holding themselves to a high standard of
truth.
Sure will get things wrong,
but the good ones have a fearless desire
to say controversial things and let the
chips fall where they may,
as Billy Wilder said,
if you're going to tell people the
truth,
be funny or they will kill you.
I guess you could say the Comedians are
guardians of peace and justice in the
galaxy.
Just like the Jetta.
Well,
except comedians usually smoke a lot.
All so I am with two of my favorite
political comics,
Felicia michaels and Jimmy Dore.
Most of you guys probably recognize them
from our old show,
but they are new.
The all new Rubin report.
What do you think of this?
This digs.
Come on.
You have a great apartment.
Pretty,
pretty sweet Jimmy.
We have a gym.
There is a camera flying around.
You love the job.
I do love the gym.
You want.
You want somebody to.
Comedy is 90 percent gap.
Ninety Percent Jib and 10 percent
eyebrow raising.
Ah.
All right.
Well then we're in good shape.
So what I wanted to start,
we're going to do all that was good.
That was good.
Uh,
so we're gonna do all politics.
All right,
let's go see.
Brought you guys on for politics.
I know you guys love politics.
So unfortunately we have to start with
Donald Trump.
I hate that we have to start this way,
but I feel that we do because this is
the thing that has just consumed
everything.
So,
uh,
I guess I'll just open it sort of
evenly.
What do you make of this trump?
You know,
the thing that irritates me most about
Donald Trump is how all my liberal
friends are freaking out.
You know what I mean?
They're always going to get his hands on
the button.
All that kind of red recognition would
you not up.
The only way he's gonna get his hands on
the button is if that's what his wife
calls his penis.
It's just so crazy to become the
president.
You have no fears that this actually
could be legit.
Well,
I,
I think anything is possible.
I hope he doesn't become president and I
mean it's scary.
The people that are attracted to him,
that scares me,
you know that he gives a voice to that.
That's frightening.
Yeah.
So we'll get to those people in a second
because I do want to talk about them.
But the.
Do you think this thing is real?
I've been saying for mines,
I think he's going to do three debates
and we've already done two,
but I think he's going to get to three.
He's still going to be peaking in the,
in the rankings.
And then he's going to say I moved the
dial.
I'm out.
And then he's gonna be the attack dog
for whoever the nominee is that,
that's my basic prediction.
Do you think this is real?
Well,
I'll say what you want about Donald
Trump.
He does make the racism run on time.
Uh,
what I do actually enjoy listening to
Donald Trump speaks just because every
once in a while you know,
I'm in the mood to watch a Hitler
documentary,
but I want to hear it delivered by Gary
Busey.
So that's why I'm really,
it's part Hitler par.
Gary Busey,
that Kinda,
that Kinda works.
Donald trump.
I predicted he would go away.
He doesn't really want to be president,
he doesn't want you running,
do anything.
He doesn't want to have to read up on
anything.
He doesn't want to have to learn
He doesn't want to have to.
But um,
so is that,
is that the craziest part of this?
Because did you see about a week ago he
was on this radio show and he asked him
the difference between Hamas and
Hezbollah,
that anyone that knows anything about
world politics,
anything,
you'd have to know a lot to know that
these are very different groups.
One is in Gaza,
one is in Lebanon and Syria,
and he made it sound like it was a
Gotcha question.
What does that,
the genius of him that every,
he turns everything into it.
You see what the media is you have to
be.
Is that the real genius of that?
That's
not the genius thing of Donald Trump
would carry the gene,
but here's the thing.
I would think the average American
doesn't know the difference between
those two factions.
And it's complicated and everything's
intertwined.
It's not a Gotcha question.
Anyone who's running for office should
know those answers and the fact that he
can just keep going at it and going at
it and not taking any responsibility for
what he doesn't know.
That's frightening,
you know,
and that people don't call them out
more.
Right.
So,
all right,
so let's talk about the people that you
mentioned,
these people that are digging this,
because I know you,
you rant and rave about politics all the
time.
You hate the system,
right?
I,
I hate the system and what I think
people are attracted to is that he's
calling the system out on their
bullshit.
So should we at least grant him that
much that he has.
You know,
when in the first debate when he said,
well,
I donated money to Hillary.
So she showed up to my,
uh,
my wedding,
like,
should,
we should give them a little credit on
that kind of thing,
right?
Yes.
He gets a,
a little,
a little credit on that,
but you will say what the genius of
Donald Trump is,
is that the geniuses that he knows,
it'll appeal to people who are not
geniuses.
Right?
Right.
So that's,
she's not appealing to smart people,
just like Ben Carson.
Right.
So Ben Carson also butts butts.
I respect Ben Carson more than I.
I do Donald Trump and I don't respect
respect Ben Carson and.
All right,
well there you go.
So trump's in negative territory.
Yeah.
So I mean,
so what he's doing is he's gaining more
support.
Ben Carson,
I ironically with racists but not
getting support with other
neurosurgeons.
Isn't that interesting?
Well,
right.
Well first off,
just Ben Carson real quick.
I mean,
can a neurosurgeon not believe in
evolution?
Don't.
Wouldn't that be a warrant to take your
license away?
The stuff that he says,
he said a couple of weeks ago that the
number one killer of African Americans
are abortions.
And when he said that,
I literally was like our cops giving
abortions and crazy.
It's so insane.
What do we do with this whole group?
I just said in the intro to this thing
that I went to the gop debate.
I talked to a couple of these guys.
I think casick is sorta a decent guy.
I think Marco Rubio is at least in the
right line of work,
even if I disagree with him on a lot of
stuff,
but what do you think about trump's
place in this?
It seems to me they all seem like
children that can't get the attention of
their dad,
you know,
he seems to be dead.
That's getting all the attention and the
kids can't.
Well,
let's go back to his supporters.
Donald Trump's.
I mean,
I'm there for instance,
women are,
it's like when he,
he said Carly Fiorina's face,
you can't have that face.
And then his poll numbers went up with
women who hate themselves.
Yeah.
So that's really what's.
And so,
and a lot of people don't say the
mainstream news media won't call him
racist.
They'll say his controversial comments
on immigration,
uh,
and they won't call them fascist,
which is exactly what this is,
what it looks like,
right?
So they're charismatic,
they're popular,
they demonize the immigrants and the
people with no money and no power as
being the problem right there over
overly nativist are naturally strong.
I'm military,
so he's,
he's got all those 14 hallmark and
misogyny is a big and fascist,
uh,
regimes,
right?
And in their culture and he's pushing
them aside,
jainism.
Right.
And I don't know if that's a word and
that sounded like a word.
So it's amazing.
So what we can say,
I'll say it here and I say it on my
show,
that,
that this is what fashion that people
go,
well,
how did Hitler happen?
Well,
he gave a good speech.
He didn't have to appeal to that many
people and that's exactly what Donald
Trump is.
So that really is.
So this is just a show,
right?
Like to me this is the ultimate reality
show.
Is that at the end of the day,
is that really what's happened?
Yes.
I'm sorry.
The only thing I want to say about when
I watched Donald Trump is the makeup
that he has on his face and I'm being
completely serious.
He's had three baby mamas.
They all are all gorgeous women that
know how to apply makeup and the fact
that he doesn't turn to his wife or one
of the former baby mamas and go,
do you think this is too much orange?
Too much wine under the ice says to me,
this is a person that doesn't give a
shit about anyone else's opinion or
doesn't care.
No,
I'm serious,
really serious.
To me as,
as a,
as a silly woman that I am,
I'm all like,
there's something wrong with that guy
that he can't turn to his woman and say,
what do you think?
What's going to be able to do that with
any subject?
He can't turn to his woman because she,
you know,
his women are anchor wives.
Last thought I'd him.
I mean,
is there something really
psychologically sort of void in someone
that's answer to everything is they love
me and I'm going to show you why
I look forward to Donald Trump's next
speech where he called another group of
people rapists and then ends up with.
But they love it,
but they love.
Yeah,
exactly.
Um,
alright,
so let's move on to the other one,
which the other big one,
which is Hillary and to me it seems like
Hillary is running,
I think the worst campaign probably in
modern history and forget the email
thing and the,
you know,
inaccessibility of the press.
There seems to be just no sort of joy or
humanity or sense of who she is or any
of that stuff.
Are you guys with me on that?
What,
what do you think about the campaign
itself?
You are correct,
Dave.
It is horrible.
She's at the beginning of the summer she
said that,
uh,
nobody stands up for progressive values
a stronger than she does.
And then just the other day she said,
Hey,
I'm a centrist.
She's bragging that she's,
that's what's wrong with the countries
knucklehead is that the center has moved
to the right.
So now when you say you're a centrist,
you're actually a Republican from the
nineties.
Right.
Okay.
And that's the problem.
So that's why Bernie Sanders had such
traction and that's why she's doing such
a bad job.
But I will say that the email thing,
it just goes to prove you because they
did,
they just came out and said that there
was,
if you don't commit a crime,
it will haunt you.
Okay.
So they've said.
So I guess the State Department has said
that she actually didn't send any
classified emails.
I don't know what to believe at this
point,
but to me the whole thing is sort of
nonsensical because one day we're just
going to have a point where the
politicians just won't use email or they
won't use any electronic communication
and they're going to do all their bad
shit by just talking to people.
You know what I mean?
Like,
so to make it about the emails itself is
sort of,
it's,
it's the,
uh,
it's the wound,
not really what's,
what's the underlying problem?
I don't think necessarily that she's
running a terrible campaign.
It could be a lot better.
I think when we were talking earlier in
the green room and you were saying,
what does she stand for?
I thought that was a great point because
no one knows what does she specifically
stand for.
You know what I mean?
We know.
Yeah.
But how's that Democrats?
But how is that possible?
There's one thing where you were like,
what is Hillary?
Like,
you can't name one thing that she likes.
Right?
So,
so I think you generally,
you basically like her,
right?
Like
I do like,
and I was telling him earlier,
I have a picture of the Gig 15 years ago
of Hillary and me and the backstage and
I'm like,
I just want her to be president for that
picture.
I mean that's a funny answer to the
seriousness of the question.
The thing is she's had so much bad news
over the past two or three months on
headlines about Bengazi all the time
about those emails and it's just insane
how much people in America don't want
its establishment candidates.
And that's the problem with her is she's
too establishment,
you know?
That's why Donald Trump is doing good.
That's why Bernie Sanders is doing good.
People want something different.
Yeah.
So I want to get to Bernie in a sec,
but I think you hit on something with
the,
with the establishment and the media.
It seems to me that the media loves
trump because they,
because of what we said earlier this off
the prompter thing,
hillary is completely scripted and I
also think the media is sort of digging
the fact that Hillary has been around
for so long and it's,
she's always had this back and forth
with the media and I think they love
just attacking her that in no way as a
defense of her,
but how much is just that the media just
loves a narrative and now it's like
we're going to take down this woman.
Yes,
that is exactly what you know.
And,
and,
uh,
not that I want to defend Hillary
Clinton,
but to be,
to,
you have to in this situation because
the New York Times just had like a
fricken vendetta against her over these
and the law.
There was nothing.
By the way,
you talk about email Hank Paulson,
who was the secretary of the treasury
when everything went belly up,
right when the whole thing cratered,
he never even used the males.
Right?
And that that's my booze email.
So that's what your point is,
is like,
well,
let's make a bigger deal out of her
emails and no one will put anything in
an email that's important.
Right?
And by the way,
we know that even when you lie under
oath,
we've talked about this a thousand
times,
like James Clapper,
who was the head of the CIA and they,
they asked him,
are we doing this mass data collection?
And he said not wittingly as he was
scratching the top of his head,
because that's where you scratch when
you're in your lie.
So we know that even when you lie,
right,
like they're not going to really do
anything.
It makes me laugh because pottery barn
does mass data collection mean everybody
does.
They know what you,
what you have in your kitchen.
They do know what I have in mind.
Yeah.
Alright.
So let's move on to Bernie because this
is the one that I think we should be
talking about more.
And I've been trying to talk about him
more.
Uh,
I think he's talking about the right
things.
Income inequality,
which is a huge problem.
He's talking about money and politics,
which nobody's talking about.
As I told you guys earlier,
I went to the gop debate.
I literally think I might've been only
person that asked anyone in that room
about money in politics.
I asked Scott Walker.
He went out of the race two days later.
I mean,
that tells you something.
So that goes back to your earlier
question about Donald Trump deserves
credit for bringing up this issue.
Yes,
he does expose the cravenness and the
and the emptiness of the political
process,
right?
Or the,
I don't know,
the complete corruption of the political
process,
but then no reporter ever says,
Hey,
what's your plan to fix that?
Nobody ever says,
hey,
that was great.
That way.
You showed everybody how you buy all
these guys on stage.
What's your plan to fix that?
Right.
And he doesn't know.
So he's also at the same time revealing
the corruption in the political process.
He's revealing the corruption and the
news media.
Right?
So the news,
me,
Chuck Todd had him on and he asked them
the Muslim question,
right?
And he started out,
this was just Sunday,
and he said,
uh,
you know,
you say that you don't have to respond
to everybody who says something and I
agree with you on that.
That's how he started his question.
So he just interrupt.
Chuck Todd just interviewed Donald Trump
after the biggest gap that you could
ever imagine,
right?
Some guy says,
let's call it let's round up Muslims.
And by the way,
the president of Muslim and trump says
yes to both of them.
Chuck Todd,
the number one political reporter in
America has them on the show,
doesn't lay a fucking glove on them or
you can delay.
And then he's like,
well,
thanks for having Donald Trump.
Says it was a pleasure and didn't know
what Chuck Todd says.
You Bet.
Yeah,
that's what he said.
So that's what's wrong with the.
And if you go,
why?
Why,
why do we have the biggest income
disparities since the gilded age?
Why do we only have five major media
corporations in America when they used
to be 50 and 1980?
Why can't we get the straight dope?
Why does when we nationalize the banks,
nobody calls it that and that's because
they're all bought and paid for by the
same people.
Read manufacturing because.
All right,
so I think your answer,
the original question was what about
Bernie?
And I think it got there in a long way
because he is talking about those
things.
So basically do you think that the media
just has a vested interest in really not
showing him?
So for example,
the other day a Bernie and trump were
both giving speeches at the same time.
And even MSNBC,
which you'd think would be,
you know,
they're supposed to lean forward or I
guess they did until two months ago.
Now I don't know that they lean
backwards or I'm not sure,
but even they were covering trump
instead of covering Bernie.
So can it.
Can an outsider like Bernie ever really
win
if he is a little bit more fun?
I'm seriously the answer why people love
trump because he's fun.
You can make fun of them.
It doesn't hurt his feelings,
you know,
and he is out of the box.
But when it comes to Bernie like they,
they're going to have to start putting
him on the tonight show,
drinking wine with a,
you know?
Yeah.
Well I saw,
I did a promo.
He did a promo for the nightly show and
he said on fleek,
which you've ever heard Bernie Sanders
say on fleek,
it was actually pretty funny.
Um,
but yes.
So how much of that is it that he's the
outsider guy so he should be getting the
Obama,
the first time Obama went around,
he should be getting that excitement.
But,
but Bernie himself,
he's a 70 something year old white guy
from.
He's not that exciting and sadly that
comb,
right?
Like,
you should shave the sides,
but you don't really like how much is
just that,
that maybe his person sadly in,
in 2015 in America that his personality
doesn't match up in the way we want to
vote for somebody.
The way his rhetoric,
which I think a lot of people agree
with.
You know,
it's funny that he,
he,
he's the big outsider on the left and
trump is the big outsider on the right.
And one of them spend zero time on their
hair and one of them here I would like
to ask Donald Trump,
does he have a long form birth
certificate for that fucking hairpiece
anyway,
so that thing definitely was not born in
America.
No one thing he talked about what you
know.
So even even msnbc wasn't covering
Bernie,
right?
Well let's.
Because Msnbc is not a liberal
corporation,
they're a corporation by the way,
through the whole Iraq war.
MSNBC was owned by General Electric,
which is a huge defense contractor.
So the lefties were left getting their
antiwar message from a fucking defense
contractor,
which is why they fired,
filled down to you because he was
against the war and they kept grits.
Matthews.
And then they also just fired Ed Schultz
because he's against the tpt and comcast
is all for the dpt.
So I said,
I already said this,
but they're not liberal.
As soon as Rachel maddow says something
that costs comcast's money,
they will fire her.
And it's just an embarrassment to her
that they haven't.
Well,
for the record or a has told me,
I can say anything I want.
It's all a fencer.
That's pretty good.
I mean it shouldn't be the fairest went
to them and if you watch the channel
like I do,
you see that they're corporatists
they're not.
Especially Chris Hayes.
He's couldn't be worse.
Yeah.
All right,
so my last thought on this is does he
have any chance?
Does Bernie have any chance?
My,
my feeling is no.
Unfortunately,
and I know people are going to give me
shit for saying that because if they'll,
they'll say to me,
if you say no,
that causes people to get depressed
about it and then they're not gonna
vote.
I just unfortunately I think that it's
very clear to me that the party is going
to not going to back him.
They simply will not back him and that's
why people are talking about Biden
because I think hillary probably will
flame out and they're gonna go with
Biden and it's like you guys are the big
party that hosts lot of minorities and
women and everything else and we're
going to pick the VP who.
Just another old white guy.
Why Dante embrace Martin is because he
is an independent and he railed so hard
against both Democrats.
I think they genuinely think he won't
win.
I think he,
they think he can't,
that are liberal for someone that far on
the left from the northeast,
just can't win the middle of the
country.
Uh,
I think it bring us home.
No,
I,
I think the reason why the Democratic
Party hasn't rallied around Bernie is
because the,
he's not in bed with the big money
donors.
And so they read the Democratic Party no
longer responds to their voters.
They only respond to their donors.
And so their donors are telling them,
get rid of this guy,
right?
We got to get rid of that guy somehow.
They don't want the donors want nothing
to do with Bernie because they can't
control them.
Just like the donors don't want anything
to do with Donald Trump because they
can't control him.
So in that sense,
they're very much alike.
And that's exactly what's happening.
We do live in a banana republic,
like we don't really have a responsible
government.
I mean,
the Sandy Hook taught us anything.
Ninety percent of the people in America
wanted some kind of gun legislation and
we didn't get it.
So I'll no longer do our representatives
represent our interests.
They only represent the donors and
that's why Bernie is winning.
And that's why he gets 30,000
people when he shows up to speak.
That's how you have to segment.
All right?
So how do you guys think we can make the
debates better?
Because I've watched both of them,
as I said,
I went to the last one.
Uh,
I tweeted on the first debate that
technically these things have not even
been debate.
A debate is where they present an idea
and then two or more people go back and
forth on these same ideas.
But basically what we've seen is
moderators ask people questions catered
to them so that they can talk about
their things.
So for example,
a jake tapper would focus with Lindsey
Graham on foreign policy because he's a
foreign policy guy,
right?
That's not a debate.
That's just sort of lobbying up
softball.
So what do you think we can do to make
these things better?
I'm back to let's make it fun and
entertaining and do it like the voice
comes on and you got three minutes to
talk.
Everyone.
Wolf Blitzer,
they all have their back to them and as
soon as he says one thing that they
like,
they turn around and he's in.
That's actually not.
So you mask the voices,
right?
Because otherwise they'll know.
Oh,
that's true.
That's just not the worst idea I've ever
heard.
I'm just saying,
uh,
the last debate which was on CNN was
fantastic because they,
instead of getting a journalist to
moderate it,
they hired Eddie Haskell.
He just kept trying to forgive anybody
to pick fights with each other.
Now Donald Trump said that you were
ugly.
What do you want to say to him?
So you're not jake tapper guys that what
you're telling me?
No,
that was the,
that was probably the worst.
By the way,
Jake Tapper,
uh,
he just announced that they're going to
be start doing fact checking of
politicians with the factcheck.org
because apparently at cnn they don't
know how to do that,
so they had to hire an outside
organization to teach them how to fact
check at CNN.
Nobody,
I'm jake tapper.
Staff really knows what they're doing.
So what that is and why there was no
real questions and why there was no
followup.
There was no candy Crowley moment at
this debate where they corrected carly
Fiorina for being a crazy person and
saying blatant lies about planned
parenthood.
What they reason they don't do that
because they don't want to alienate any
of the viewers that like these people.
So what they'll do is they say,
hey,
Jeb Bush said this,
Donald Trump said that.
What do you want to say to him?
Instead of saying,
Hey,
the facts are this,
and you said this,
how do you don't do that?
So they're not doing journalism.
They're doing Eddie Haskell,
ISM and they're trying to get people to
pick fights with each other.
Yeah,
I do agree with you,
but on the other hand,
that question needed to be asked to
Carla feared the quest,
the face thing that needed to be asked
about trump saying,
you know,
calling her out on her looks or
whatever.
I mean,
that is so terrible that it needed to be
at.
So I agree with you.
It had to be addressed because it was
just another absurdly misogynistic thing
that trump did,
but interestingly doesn't that then get
more of the play the next day then
anything that might be more important
such as foreign policy or immigration.
I mean really can you think of any
headline the next day that was related
to policy?
Important things,
but it's important how a person who is
running for president is treating the
women of this country.
Yeah,
that totally is as important.
Okay.
I totally,
and the GLP did make it clear that they
welcome all women into the gop.
Even the ones who make Donald Trump
wins.
All right,
so we haven't had a democratic debate
yet where you have one in a couple of
weeks in Vegas,
right?
As I said that about Bernie segment,
you know the Democrats were supposed to
be the big party.
That's what everyone says.
They're supposed to be the big party,
but they've really only got two people
running for all intents and purposes.
Right?
Hillary and Bernie,
and then there's Jim Webb and and
o'malley.
Well,
but,
but it's really only two people that
everyone's talking about.
So should we give the Republicans a
little credit for at least they have 20
clowns in there,
clown car while in the democratic clown
car.
There's really only two people.
Well,
Martin O'malley did come out last week
with a bold proposal.
He said,
raise the age of gun ownership to 21
years old,
and everybody responded by saying who
the fuck?
But that's my point.
You know what?
I'm going to call us,
call something crazy here.
I think that that guy who's polling at
negative 60,
that nobody knows who he is.
I think he has a little bit of a chance
here because I think they're all going
to get equal footing and people are so
sick of Hillary on the debates.
Yeah,
and I think I,
I think he'd bring him,
he's a good looking,
middle aged guy and I and I think he's a
pretty decent guy and I think people are
suddenly going to go,
who the hell is this guy?
The irony is that it was Howard Dean
who,
whose idea was to limit the number of
democratic debates because he saw what
happened with all the Republican debates
last time and how they ate each other
and how it was just a clown show and so
we didn't want that to happen with the
Democrat,
so they made them limit them,
but now we realized,
hey,
there's actually going to be a real
debate now so maybe we should do more of
these because this is just free
advertising for the Republican Party and
we're not getting ready for the
Democrats and people still don't know
where Bernie Sanders is.
Right?
So what can,
what can we do?
We got the election is over a year away,
right?
What can we do to make these debates
better?
Like as the people,
like do we have to demand that they have
to be done on pbs?
I mean they were done,
I don't know if there's going to be any
of this upcoming year,
but for years ago some of them were done
at pbs.
I mean something.
How do we get it out of the Gotcha thing
out of the.
Does carly have a wrinkle
on a face now?
What?
The answer for that as.
I mean it is going to be interesting to
finally see Bernie and Hillary go at it,
you know,
but how do you make it more interesting
and maybe they need to have someone like
at the Oscars who did the little clips
always beforehand.
You know what I mean?
To billy crystal come in and write.
I don't know or I mean what do you.
It used to be that the League of women
voters used to organize the baits and
other people use it and then they got
smart and they were like,
hey,
we can't let other people choose.
The people are going to ask us
questions.
We want to control everything.
So they created this presidential
commission on debates and now so now
there isn't any more.
We League of women,
so it's all controlling everything,
which is why they suck,
right?
So somebody has to stand up like maybe
women or some other big organizations
say,
hey,
we want to have our own debate,
like the Naacp members saying we're
going to have our own debate at our
thing and we were inviting people and
then it'll be telling who doesn't show
up.
Right.
So that's the way they should do it.
Unfortunately we know that the parties,
the parties won't back that they will
because they have.
But Bernie Sanders is show up.
He'll show up and he'll do it a little
bit.
Maybe that would be good.
Alright.
So let's move on to what I think was the
big elephant in the room or
unfortunately not.
Come on.
Jimmy Dore,
a giant of it.
The money in politics thing.
It is,
seems pretty obvious to me that we have
a couple like real issues in America
right now.
The money in politics that's ruined our
political system.
We've got,
you know,
political correctness run amok,
but nobody talked about money in
politics.
As I said before,
I think I might've been the only person
to ask them a question on this.
Why do we not talk?
We did talk about it wasn't near Mccain
Feingold thing 10 years ago.
We used to sorta talk about it every now
and again.
Nobody talks about it now.
Right?
Talk about it.
I don't understand how we allow people
to run for president as a candidate when
they still owe money from the last time
they tried.
Literally.
I think Hillary might be in debt still
from the previous thing.
If you owe money from the last time you
didn't get elected done,
you can't run this time until you've
paid everybody off.
It is striking in outrageous at people
don't mention it or talk about it.
I think it's terrible.
I mean it's.
That's the only answer.
I mean,
what,
how do you fix that though?
How do you fix that?
Well,
I did notice that when I asked some of
the campaign people this and even when I
asked Scott Walker,
they just,
they just link a couple of words to get
there to put it,
to make a sentence and then you move on
because they know they're not going to
be asked this and they know no one
cares.
That's what I really realized that when
I asked them that there was a sense of
that,
that stupid question like nobody cares
about that.
Asked me the.
Asked me that question,
you know,
so,
so what do we do about that?
You know,
we a wolf-pack.com,
Dave.
That's how we,
there's a bunch of orders.
That's the organization I'm a part of
that helps get money out of politics and
what you have to do is you have to pass
a constitutional amendment right to get
money out of politics.
Hillary Clinton,
by the way,
you said she's in favor of it,
so we don't.
I will.
That'll be,
that's good to hear.
Also,
the Senate also in the United States
Congress also passed a resolution to
open debate on this.
So that's a good thing.
And three states has since we've been
trying to push this,
I've already passed the California being
one of them,
Illinois and I think we have a New
Hampshire,
Vermont.
Uh,
so that's what you need to do.
You need to get the states,
you have to go at the state level.
They have much less controlled for
whatever reason on the state capital.
Sure.
So we can make an.
So that's my big solution.
We have to get money and you can't fix
anything.
Why are we still debate in climate
change?
Because big money,
right?
Why are we still debating?
Should we drill in the Arctic because of
big money?
I.
Why are we still bombing nonstop for 30
years in the middle of the big money?
So is that.
So that's really the crux of that.
The reason we can't get the public to be
ginned up enough to care is because
they're getting their information from
the very people who are paying for the
operation to keep them dumb.
The criminals bought the watchdog,
right?
The watch dog used to be a,
the Walter cronkite and 60 minutes and
then they got smart and I said,
hey,
let's just buy them.
And they bought them and so now the guys
who are working for the people are
supposed to be exposing,
so that's why they are literally
working.
So that's how you go,
well,
how do we,
how do we get it into a rack war that
lasted?
That's how you get it because the people
are working for the defense contractors.
They're supposed to be exposing defense
contractors and they're not.
That's what,
yeah,
there's a reality where it will ever
turn around.
Uh,
yes.
I think if we get money out of politics.
And so.
So it happened before,
right?
So Teddy Roosevelt came along and he did
the antitrust legislation,
right?
They used to call them trust back then
because they would take.
Anyway,
that was the.
So now that's what we need.
We need him and then we need FDR.
FDR stood up and said,
never before in the history of America
has the money.
People have been more organized in their
hatred for one candidate,
and I welcome their hatred.
Could you imagine,
can you imagine anyone,
anyone saying that today?
Besides Bernie Sanders?
Right?
So you,
I had a little inspiration from you
first because it sounded like it could
happen,
but then I just thought,
well,
if we get hillary is president or let's
say we get Jeb Bush.
Pretty sure they're not making that
speech.
I think we're going to have a
revolution.
If that happens,
we may.
Well never have.
I'm going to buy a gun.
Yeah.
All right.
So let's,
uh,
let's talk about religion and politics
because then,
because that's the other big one.
And look a Guy Mike Huckabee's up there.
This is a guy that the week before was
defending Kim Davis and everyone knows
about Kim Davis and not giving the
marriage licenses to gay people.
And Mike Huckabee actually defended her
by saying you shouldn't,
you shouldn't,
you know,
partake in the law that you don't
believe is moral.
That is the most ridiculous anti
American thing you could possibly do.
It shows that profound lack of
understanding of how government works.
At our constitution and all that.
So,
but there's,
there's him,
there's crews,
there's Santorum and these guys.
And even now a Ben Carson,
what do we do about this conversation?
Religion should have nothing.
We have separation of church and state.
I think.
What,
what do we do about it?
Well,
I was googling this topic matter earlier
and I saw that the boy scouts don't
allow atheists in the boy scouts.
Right?
And I was thinking it's people don't
want to trust other people who aren't
religious or can pretend to be
religious,
you know,
with decisions that are going to impact
them.
I kind of get it.
But on the other hand,
have you ever been around?
I have aunts that are so religious,
they are evil,
you know?
Has there ever been around people like
that,
you know?
Uh,
I went to Catholic school,
right?
That's what you and,
and when I look at the Republican,
a spectrum out there,
the candidates,
I'm like,
oh my God,
these people evil.
I mean,
if,
if you have blinders like this about
religious and how everyone has to follow
the same religion or the same thing that
you're doing,
I mean that is just as bad as someone
who has a void of it and I know that
just as bad as those horrible,
a secular values.
I know.
It's just as equally horrible.
Wow.
What is this?
Is this the irony of.
Is this the irony of Republicans that
they say they want small government,
right?
Yes.
They say they want some other way and
then at the same time they keep jamming.
[inaudible] everyone.
I didn't live those notes.
Yeah,
because you said your question is how do
we get religion out of government in my
whole thing is they should be made to go
to an religious.
People should have to take an irony
class.
Right?
Right.
Yep.
Kim Davis,
who's thrice divorced,
making a religious stand for the
sanctity of marriage,
that's,
you know,
and,
and now the oath keepers have promised
to defend her and they don't want to
lock her up again.
She's so grateful.
She promised to marry three or four of
them.
So.
And then they played that song right
through it with a tiger and so when she
came out and she and she got in trouble
for that because they didn't want her
to.
Survivor doesn't want to use that song.
But she said she liked that song so
much.
She's going to play it at our next three
weddings.
The point is day.
I have a lot of these jokes.
She ruined rocky for me.
It's just so.
But what about Huckabee?
So someone like Huckabee,
who's supposedly like,
to me this is,
this is proof that he's not running for
president and he's running to run the
Christian,
right?
Yes.
He.
And I wish people would just say that as
I wish almost he could say that and he
could say,
you know what,
I'm up on this stage because I do
control or at least want to control a
portion of this country and I want to
keep controlling it.
And then we can be honest about it.
And then he would disappear when he
gets,
when the is go further.
But he's not really running for
president.
Right?
Isn't he running his own?
That degree of power?
I think you're very perceptive.
Dave Bliss is.
I think why you have your own show once
in a while and yes,
that is exactly what he's doing.
He's running to get speaking fees.
He's running to be the biggest Christian
onstage.
So non whoever does become president.
He's like the Billy Graham.
They have to come through him to get to
the religious right that they're going
to need.
So it's all that.
He's the biggest charlatan of all of
them because at least Donald Trump who
is a big asshole won't take that extra
step of putting the cross on his sleeve
like,
like a pocket he was and how it can be
as complete phony.
Right?
And trump.
Not that I ever wanted to defend trump,
but you know,
they asked trump about the gay marriage
thing and he said,
look,
the Supreme Court made a decision.
I,
I would have to abide by the Supreme
Court.
That shows a better understanding of how
government works.
Then Santorum or Huckabee,
who want you to just pick which laws can
you imagine if we could all just pick.
Well,
I'm not going to pay taxes morally.
I don't think I should have.
Yeah,
yeah.
Separate but equal.
So that means we can just ignore it.
No,
that's not that sounds right.
But I do like what you're saying about
he's running to get a speaking
engagement,
but then the reality is how much money
is he spending to try to run for
president versus how much you would
actually ever make
as a space spending his own money.
Right?
So he's not.
Yeah,
it's not his.
And ultimately it's not about the
speaking money per se,
as much as just the influence that he
will just run the Christian,
right?
Like be the next billy Graham or
somebody.
But I want to backup the saying that you
said early about this,
this atheist thing,
because the first two episodes of the
show we had Sam Harris,
who's probably the most outspoken
atheist and Carrie Santa Maria.
Uh,
also an atheist.
And we talked a little bit about,
I'm atheist and politics and every poll
shows that people would never vote for
an atheist.
People hate atheist.
Why are we so afraid of secularism?
I think this is sort of what you were
saying before.
Why are we afraid of people that would,
that would base their decisions on the
law of the land and not the imaginary.
I think it's because everyone has this
like ultimate fantasy of the.
You get to be president.
Something terrible goes down somewhere.
He has his finger on the button,
right?
Like what?
What's going to happen?
You want to know that your president is
going to be in that dark space in his
room before he asked to make some
terrible decision like,
dear God,
you want the comfort of knowing it's a
whole facade.
It's a fake,
but you don't want that.
You know what I mean?
You don't want someone that's just like
this is the line,
the column of good things that'll
happen.
This is the column of bad things I
think,
because people want to be able to hang
hope on a president and,
and as weird as it sounds,
I think what he is,
you don't hang on.
Sorry,
I'm sorry for the fact that I think it's
the same thing with gay people.
Uh,
people were against gay marriage until
they knew a gay person and I think
people are afraid of atheists until they
known atheist.
I was against gay marriage to like
hockey married.
I'm now,
I'm okay there.
But um,
what do you think about it?
That's what I really think it is.
Yeah.
People just don't know atheists and they
think,
well,
they're dying.
In fact,
they kind of be quitting with devil
worshipers know.
It's like,
no,
there are no worshiping nothing,
which is exactly why I've been saying on
the show repeatedly.
Yeah,
the atheist have to come out.
I think the atheist movement should do
that.
The most important thing that gay people
ever did was come out.
And I think that that's what's next for
atheism.
Maybe we should start calling ourselves
something else.
Like,
I like the term non theist.
Yeah,
I like that.
It sounds better.
It doesn't.
It's like I'm not into the shift.
Right,
but don't you hate that you even have to
associate with the term doesn't that in
itself,
it's like then you're in the club,
what club would,
why me kind of thing.
Yes and that.
Yes,
and I don't agree that there is such a
thing as militant atheism.
I don't,
I don't agree.
That's like saying you're a militant,
logical person.
I will apply logic to every situation.
You know,
all these atheists that are getting
rallies together to hurt people.
It's just not happening.
Not.
All right,
well that's a perfect segue to the next
thing I want to talk about,
which is the PC culture that we seem to
live in.
So I have two comedians.
This is our job more than anything else
is to,
is to get to that line and figure out
where it is and push it.
Maybe cross it every now and again.
I think we live in a very bizarre time
where we have trigger warnings now in
these social justice warriors and every
time anyone says anything,
you say something about women they don't
like,
they they.
You're now,
you hate women.
You say something about any minority you
don't like or you say anything about gay
people.
You automatically hate all of them.
That we automatically jumped to the
conclusion that it's based in racism or
xenophobia.
Especially for Comedians.
This is a seriously dangerous slope,
right?
He knows the worst with that.
The Puerto Ricans.
Yeah.
I don't think it's so much about pc
culture.
I just think everyone has a knee jerk
reaction.
People are like this now.
Why are people like this now?
Everyone is so angry and no one just
wants to enjoy jokes or have fun
anymore.
Every.
Everything has to be a purpose.
Like now they have the new normal
Barbie.
It's a Barbie doll that has stretch
marks and pimples,
unnormal Barbie and I just,
you know,
why can't people just have toys and not
reading a million things?
Why does everything have to have a 100
percent purpose or you know what I mean?
Be without any humor or anything.
Do you think that that actually takes
something very special away from
childhood that,
you know,
I played with Gi Joe or human or
transformers and the imagination,
I've got to use my imagination to make
up this world and you know,
figure out things that I thought and
whatever,
where now you're going to make
everything so realistic for these kids
and have them have every fear and
everything that might upset them,
but you're going to send a bunch of
robots and by the way,
they're drugged,
right?
They're all on every drug known to man
because of,
you know,
whatever,
that we're going to send them out into a
world drugged and afraid of everything.
That's pretty dangerous combination.
Right.
You know,
giving back to the PC thing,
you are correct that some,
some people are to knee jerk and cry a
racism or whatever,
antisemitism.
But there are,
there is racism and there is.
So that's the thing.
That's where it's like murky right here,
like,
well I don't want to get into a point
where we just shout so now because the
right wing does a thing where they shop
every time there actually is racism.
They go,
oh,
you're just too PC.
No,
that's not being too pc.
Right.
So that,
for example,
that would be when the right will say
that Christians are actually the most
under attack in America,
which is of course completely or the
Christian is going to have their day in
America,
Dave,
someday they're going to have a guy
maybe in the White House to run things.
So yes.
You know,
the thing that Jerry Seinfeld rights for
that came up with,
he was complaining about pc culture on
campus.
I haven't in colleges in a year but I
mean in a couple of years,
but I noticed when I used to play
colleges that the higher their tuition,
the more freedom I got to say whatever I
wanted.
And it was interesting.
Yeah.
The,
so the lower the tuition,
you know,
I don't know if the DM or the kids or
whatever.
I don't know.
I went to a shoe that's very politically
incorrect.
Yeah,
I know that's politically incorrect.
So I went to a suny school and I'm a
dumb guy so I can say that and uh,
uh,
don't look up where I went.
Went to jail.
The point is it sucked.
George Bush went there.
Well,
that whole thing.
Trigger war.
Yes,
it's,
I,
when I first for,
of course dancer,
there's going to be someone who reads
something and it's going to fuck them
up.
Will you can't pass a law about it,
you know,
that's their own problem they have to
deal with.
Do you know when I hear what I hear a
car horns,
I freak out.
I can't pass a law that says nobody can
beat their horn anymore.
Right?
So is the bigger fear.
I used to fear that the first amendment
would disappear,
that the government would take our free
speech.
But what I'm starting to fear now,
although I am no big fan of the
government in any capacity,
what I'm starting to fear now is that
ultimately we're just going to take our
freedoms away.
We're going to get so afraid of saying
anything and I see this happen all the
time.
Now I get emails,
not that I'm the most politically
incorrect person there is,
but I get emails now.
People saying that I'm saying things
that they wish they could say and it
seems to me that people are censoring
themselves already,
so I fear that I fear the self
censorship because of all this more than
I fear that the government's going to
come in and take away our right to free
speech.
Do you.
Where do you.
Where do you fall on that?
All?
I want to say this.
I was just working vegas last weekend.
There was one set where I was having.
It was a little bit,
the crowd was tight and a guy was
sitting with his arms crossed and I for
15 years I've always said,
oh,
you know our endoscopes.
Do you want to let them go?
Or you know,
three guys sitting,
you guys where's the girls and all that
were that,
you know,
that is totally hacky,
but it Kinda gets the crowd,
you know,
going when you're in the mood.
But now people aren't buying into those
jokes and it was a realization of wow,
people really rpc,
but it's a good thing.
So I think there is a legitimate reason
to be pc.
We're growing as people and and there
are things we don't accept anymore.
We don't accept racism anymore.
We don't accept making jokes about gays
anymore.
And that's a good thing.
I think the comedians that say,
oh,
it's too pc to pc,
they might be correct,
but in other words,
maybe you need to change to the idea.
That's interesting because Sarah
Silverman said something to that effect
this week and in an interview,
and I think she was directing it at
Seinfeld because Seinfeld basically was
saying,
you know,
I used to make this gay joke about a
French king and his loose,
you know,
his hand like this and now they think
it's too offensive.
But I would always be on this.
I don't know you to call Seinfeld.
Politically incorrect.
I don't know what he thinks about
anything either thinks about anything.
Did you hear what he said about that
cotton ball?
Yeah,
exactly.
All right,
so my,
my weight,
my final,
but yeah,
wonderful final thought about this
because there's comes a time,
right?
Like so now we've come a long way with
how gay people are treated in our
society in a positive way,
but there's guys who were born at a
certain age,
like Alec Baldwin,
they grew up using gay terms as slurs
and insults and then when that lizard
brain gets activated,
when you're angry at someone,
those things come up.
Right.
And so Alec Baldwin got in trouble for
calling a guy a cock sucking faggot.
Right?
But he said he called him a cock sucking
bedhead because apparently cocksuckers
gender neutral,
but no one swears like that.
No one.
Nobody says a $4,
swear word and then follows it up with
the cartoons.
Nobody goes,
oh,
you mother fucking farks narco.
Right,
right.
So that's good people.
A little bit of a leash if you grew up.
Yeah.
Especially if he apologizes or our lies
are lies about it.
Like I haven't.
Baldwin did,
right?
No.
If he apologizes.
Look,
my dad said racist things when I was
growing up.
My Dad would never do it now,
but he should get bull connor.
But when I was growing up as a 27 year
old man or a 30 year old man,
he said stuff and my brother made would
be like director and now he would never
do that because everyone grows at a
different rate,
you know,
people are learning at different ages
and you know.
Um.
All right.
So I apologize at least.
So
yeah.
So I thought that the,
the right way to end something with
comedians would be to talk about counter
culture a little bit because
counterculture is what standup grew out
of,
right?
It used to be cool to fight the system.
Yes.
And I feel like it's not cool to fight
the system anymore.
You're thought of as crazy or something
or something.
I think it has a lot to do with that.
Most comics are liberal.
Most comics really,
at least at the beginning,
really liked Obama.
So everybody would say,
oh,
it's tough to make jokes about this guy
because he's rational and speaks clearly
and he is not making all the grammatical
errors that Bush was making.
Um,
now it's changed and I think people
don't necessarily like Obama as much or
at least people on the left that field
that he's,
you know,
been more right wing.
I think certainly that's what you think.
But we don't have a real counterculture
anymore.
How do we need a Republican in office to
have a true counterculture?
Would that actually help the country?
People have someone that I believe in,
nothing that they actually stand for
the argument that would strengthen the
argument has been made that Barack Obama
being the head of the government right
now splits the opposition because
they're the people.
So we should be opposing him about the
indefinite detention,
TPP,
you know,
all that stuff that Syria war with.
You and I are on the same page on this.
So we should.
So what?
By Barack Obama being the head of the
government,
he splits the opposition because half
the people are loyalty and then the
other half the people are telling the
truth or wanting to push back and
protest against a terror radical
government are bullshit that they see in
the government.
And so it doesn't happen.
That's exactly what's happening and that
is what happened and that's why there is
no counterculture.
Good enough for you to pick up on it.
I get a couple every episode I get one
or two bring,
bring us home,
bring it up.
Well,
uh,
I was watching Bill Maher the other
night and he was of course making fun of
Republicans and George Pataki was on
there and it's gotten to the point
where,
yeah,
you want to have one Republican in the
mix when you're talking politics and
doing the counterculture thing,
all that.
But even George Pataki's like,
well my poverty and it's just an
indication of we've just all moved to
the right,
right.
So maybe we do need a Republican in
office to wake up the people to actually
realize what's important.
Yes.
And,
and it would at least be good for
comedians.
Alright.
Right.
On that note,
I want to thank Felicia Michael's,
Jimmy Dore.
You can follow them.
Twitter and Youtube and websites.
They got all that stuff and we're going
to put some of it right beneath you.
And Jimmy's got a book.
It's called your country's just not that
into you.
Yeah,
they are.
All books are sold everywhere.
There you go.
All right.
Thanks for watching guys.
And we will do it again next week.